[Music]
I thought it was someone else's affair somewhere. Even if
I saw the person in 262,
it might not be related to me. I
got on Franks and we have a limit
. I've been taught that for a long time.
[Music]
I was really worried about 3 tubes
I was scared to put it into words, not just Miku
, I was always worried
[Music]
Hmm, I want to know the current situation,
Nana  I was writing a letter to Mr. Hachi and Mr. Hachi,
so I didn't receive
it again. I've already done this.
Even if it was true that we were abandoned by my dad,
I thought
everyone.  I'm not worried because I'm with you, I think I'll be
able to do something with
everyone. Actually, it was a lot of fun to cook rice together today.
I
didn't say it wasn't fun because it wasn't so much.
Yui Yeah,
I think we only wanted to fight
all the time. I also enjoyed it. I couldn't eat everything, but
I should make it again.
It's fun and important to talk about making rice and taking a bath
now. I think
this is where we are
. Let's think that
riding Franks is not the only place for us.  I'm
sure
[music]
me